[Musique]
nous sommes le 3 juillet bienvenue sur
tv 78 voici le sommaire de ce 3 juillet
pour le 7 8 sél les invités invité donc
aujourd'hui philippe pas un président
général de l'antenne par ile-de-france
yvelines de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie il est en
plateau pour évoquer l'ouverture de la
saison touristique nous verrons aussi
comment il se positionne face à la
concurrence la mise en place de la loi
obligeant à notamment le loir d'un
logement meublé à une formalités
d'enregistrement du moins si à la
commune le décide et puis vous
rencontrez au vent contre aurait aussi
tout à l'heure michel laugier le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et frank leboeuf l'ancien champion de
football
il sera question du baril les djeuns
championship c'est le tournoi français
est du seigneur tour européen qui va se
dérouler du 28 au 30 septembre sur
l'albatros du golf national bonsoir
philippins on débute donc avec vous
président de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie
vous tenez aussi le royal rue royale à
versailles
nous sommes au tout début du mois de
juillet les vacances scolaires ce sera à
partir de vendredi la saison estivale
débute est lancé est ce que
véritablement ça se ressent déjà pour
vous et on verra ensuite comment se
positionne un peu la région en matière
de tourisme pendant l'été mais vous déjà
est-ce que vous ressentez le début de
cette saison
oui on ressent enfin on a encore une
activité une activité j'ai envie de dire
économique et au niveau du tourisme
d'affaires parce qu'il ya encore des
congrès jusqu'au 14 juillet notamment il
ya un gros congrès sur versailles les
yvelines et donc on en profite donc
jusqu'au 14 juillet je dirais que c'est
très bien après le 14 juillet sa chute
car justement comment se passe la saison
estivale sur un secteur comme solides de
versailles et plus généralement sur le
département quand on pense vacances en
place plutôt forcément en montagne mer
pas forcément au tourisme culturel même
s'il n'ya pas que ça à faire dans la
région mais comment se positionne aux
établissements versailles a toujours été
une ville étudie le culturel de toute
façon donc c'est une étape et j'ai envie
de dire
obligé pour certains quand ils
traversent la france où des touristes
qui atterrissent à 3 6 10 rebonds ont
fait une halte à versailles rien le
château ont fait un pari de my life puis
après on continue et le séjour dans la
course ont baissé c'est très court ça
toujours été très courts et à versailles
il essaie même ultra court puisque en
fait qui visite le château ont une après
midi aurait une journée et qu'ils
arrivent le matin à des touristes
arrivent le matin ils repartent le soir
donc c'est très très court no la
majorité des hôtels versailles est en
fait vous allez au tour fonctionne avec
le tourisme d'affaires une société les
réunions les conventions les congrès
donc ça c'est jusqu'au 4 juillet ça va
après sa chute un peu après bon on avait
les fêtes de nuits aussi qu'ils
commencent au château de versailles
donc ça profite aussi pas mal pour le
week-end des samedi ça remplit les
samedis et non par un traitement de
versailles si on élargit un peu à
l'ensemble du département puisque vous
êtes allée charles en charge de l'union
des métiers des industries de
l'hôtellerie mais pour toutes les deux
français pour les yvelines sur ce
secteur ile de france yvelines c'est un
peu plus large je pense à la vallée de
chevreuse par exemple tourisme différent
le tourisme est différent oui tout à
fait et j'ai même dans le nord eglin du
sud yvelines on n'a pas les mêmes les
mêmes attentes
par exemple dans le mantois gc les bords
de seine sont bien fréquentées mais bon
après si on va plus dans le centre du
département c'est sûr que c'est un peu
plus calme
versailles bénéficie du château et des
alentours donc aussi mais c'est pas non
c'est pas hautement touristique mais
c'est une étape c'est une bonne étape il
ya un enjeu particulier pour pour cet
été par rapport au précédent de saison
par rapport à cette période difficile du
tourisme
plus généralement avec ces menaces
terroristes notamment bas le valasse
j'aimerais dire on a appris à vivre avec
début d'année d'ailleurs a été pas si
bon que ça justement s'est maintenue
quand même premier semestre a été un peu
bon
dans la tente remet mais avec tous les
ponts et tout ça ça a été un peu moyen
mais ce n'est pas trop mal tiré je veux
un très bon comme d'habitude
bon faut dire qu'on à limiter un peu la
casse dans l'hôtellerie même
d'hôtellerie de luxe a aussi subi aussi
tous ses effets là mais bon on essaie de
l'enjeu c'est de faire rester le maximum
de gens dans le département mais bon ils
ont leur itinéraire et c'est pas
toujours facile
vous avez dressé un peu le bilan de ces
derniers mois si on remonte encore un
petit peu
est-ce que l'année a été plutôt bonne
pour le tourisme alors là plutôt
d'affaires cette fois ci sur secteur des
yvelines sur versailles aussi pour le
tourisme d'affaires oui je pense que
c'est pas mal oui il ya toujours un bon
un bon vivier il ya bon volume
économique là dessus sur sur le tourisme
d'affaires
mais c'est le tourisme j'ai envie de
dire qui le tourisme classique là tous
nos loisirs qu'ils aient du mal à
revenir le français surtout mais les
chinois commencent à revenir ça c'est
sûr depuis le début de l'année on voit
alors qu'est le retour des fusions ces
derniers temps un bail avec les japonais
les japonais ont du mal à revenir
mais les chinois eux continuent à venir
est de plus en plus nombreux de par la
menace terroriste notamment de par cet
état de la menace
il ya un autre point aussi important
c'est notre volet de cet entretien avec
vous ce soir c'est la concurrence parce
que les loueurs par exemple de logements
meublés sont de plus en plus nombreux il
ya cet élément internet nouveau airbnb
pour ne pas citer ce site internet qui
simplifie la mise en relation entre
entre les clients et les loueurs parce
que c'est un vrai manque à gagner pour
vous et comment vous réagissez façade
7,7 cette concurrence aujourd'hui
oui clairement ça manque à gagner
puisque aussi on alex des chiffres entre
l'hôtellerie et eu clairement eux sont
en progression de leur chiffre
d'affaires si je puis dire d'au moins
30% nous on est en belle sens entre 5 et
20% dont je profite oui tout à fait de
cette manne touristique et de cette
facilité qu'ont les touristes à réserver
ces vrais faux la wii
nous la profession n'est pas contre ce
concept c'est qu'on est contre le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas d'équité fiscale c'est
tout c'est pour ça qu'on a mis l'accent
depuis des années on a obtenu gain de
cause à travers la loi le maire du 28
avril 2017 qui stipule que maintenant
bien devra être enregistrées devra
posséder un numéro d'enregistrement un
enregistrement pourquoi déjà pour les
communes pour les tracés pour pouvoir
collecter la taxe de séjour qui est
normal tout et période bergeron
touristique et ensuite à terme aussi
appliquer des décrets sur la
transparence des transactions des des
plateformes hier quand il faut que les
plateformes le trésor public sache ce
qu'il se passe ce qu'il ya comme
transactions ce qui passe en france ou
pas est-ce qu'il ya des améliorations
encore apporter au système où les les
améliorations vous venez de mentionner
commencent à porter leurs fruits et ça
suffit à rééquilibrer le système là
c'est tout c'est tout frais de l'umih
nationale on a on vient juste de lancer
justement une campagne qui s'appelle va
voir ton mer donc justement pour en
envoyer le quitte
le kit tout à 1500 communes de france
justement qui comprend un extrait de
délibérations un exemple comment
collecter la taxe qui leur explique
comment mettre en place cet
enregistrement
donc on leur a bien lâché le travail si
je puis dire et donc on his villa a mis
cette délibération le 23 juillet son
conseil municipal strasbourg va le faire
bientôt
lyon aussi versailles aussi et
je pense qu'il ya d'autres comiques qui
vont suivre beaux gosses mais bon c'est
un premier pas là on est vers un
rééquilibrage voie législative en tout
cas mais est ce que je vaux six en tant
que co teulier professionnels du
tourisme de l'hôtellerie
ça vous pousse aussi à proposer
peut-être de nouveaux services à revoir
un peu votre offre à modifier un peu la
façon de travailler
non pas vraiment parce que nous on est
dans une hôtellerie familiale et
indépendante nous on a eu toujours le
souci du contact très simple avec le
client c'est une entreprise familiale en
face à on a toujours eu donc après 1,6
et d auteuil qui court de la place oui
pourquoi pas ils peuvent aménager et 10
des petites îles et dans leur lobby des
centres d'aidé coin qui sont
intéressants qui peuvent aller aux
enfants qui peut améliorer enfin bon
pour accueillir le client mais ya pas de
révolution par rapport à cette offre
c'est qu'on peut pas concurrencer une
offre airbnb à versailles je vois à
quelques mètres du château vous avez 1
70 mètre carré quasiment à 60 euros la
nuit soit 5,0 l'année pour une famille
de 6 et moi même on le vend deux étoiles
donc économique je suis à 100 120 euros
pour une chambre familiale
oui on peut pas concurrencer tout la
nécessité de régulariser des
investissements législatif à un tout
dernier mot si justement pour cet
au-delà de la période estivale même vous
deviez vendre ce territoire des yvelines
vous diriez quoi aux touristes
éventuelles il ya plein de choses à
visiter ses formidables en fait il ya
vous avez le culturel et le loisir vous
allez sur les bords de bougival aussi
vous fait vous avez des balades en
radeau sur les bords de seine d'ailleurs
rien il ya un grand plan sur un grand
une stratégie qui ce touriste ticket qui
menait la par la cci par les
départements aussi qui s'appelle spot
tourisme 1 qui vise à valoriser tous les
la vallée de la seine
donc ça c'est très important donc on
aura vraiment dans les îles du nord à
une offre culturelle très riche et en
même temps de loisirs merci beaucoup
d'être venu à saint brieuc si vous me
plateau parler tourisme donc philippin
président de l'antenne paris de france
yvelines de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie merci à vous
nous poursuivons ce 7,8 invité mardi 27
juin avait lieu en plein coeur de paris
sur la scène le coup d'envoi officiel de
la deuxième édition de la paris les
djeuns championship comme l'année
dernière le rendez vous réunira à la fin
du mois de septembre
les anciennes légendes
circuit européen au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parmi les
cinquante quatre golfeurs il y aura
l'américain john daly ou encore le
français jean van de velde
mais ces sportifs seniors ne viendront
pas pour faire de la figuration selon
l'ancien footballeur français franck
leboeuf qui était présent sur le
lancement de l'opération
et puis le président a de saint quentin
en yvelines michel laugier michael et
demi d'euros les a rencontrés tous les
deux alors je suis avec michel le g et
franck leboeuf nous allons parler du
paris les djeuns championship qui a déjà
eu une édition au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines michel auger
deuxième édition qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
deuxième édition est très heureux
d'accueillir cette deuxième édition déjà
la première s'est passé dans
d'excellentes conditions et c'est vrai
que ça fait plaisir de voir tous ces
anciens joueurs avoir toujours un niveau
intéressant que vous vous êtes déjà les
sera la première édition non m'a pas
invité
non mais non j'ai pas eu le temps c'est
vrai que on se connaît mais plutôt du
théâtre est ce que je vais souvent un
motif retenu qui est juste à côté et mes
deux yvelines voilà c'est ça et donc
j'ai pas eu j'ai pas eu l'occasion et la
chance de faire ce ce tournoi mais
pourquoi pas un jour qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
ce tournoi ben moi je trouve ça c'est
génial parce que c'est vrai que en fait
les gens restent des sportifs et
sportives et sportifs ont toujours envie
de compétition il ya toujours quelque
chose et puis et puis c'est toujours
sympa jusqu'à on sait pourquoi on joue
au golf parce que c'est un sport très
difficile
ce qui ne m'a énormément concentration
mais surtout on aime bien être entre
potes et c'est vrai et c'est c'est
souvent le cas dans sa dans ce tournoi
c'est du niveau de l'open de france ou
un peu moins c'est la question je vais
pas faire de comparaison ce sont deux
compétitions différentes en tout cas
date bien sûr le plaisir à accueillir
cet open de france dans quelques jours
mais par contre dès le taux de
intelligente aussi c'est quelque chose
d'important savez une tournée de légende
aujourd'hui il ya aussi des chanteurs
qui font des tours d y arriver
académique études je crois que c'est
important parce que ça reste quand même
quelque chose de très grande qualité
dont tous ceux qui veulent passer un bon
moment peut venir à l'année dernière
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à les voir
tout ce qu'ils ont fait rêver ya
quelques années mais que deux font
toujours rêver parce qu'on est loin
d'avoir le niveau j'étais amateur de
golf
est ce que vous pourriez participer un
jour à ce tournoi des légendes
ouh là là il va falloir peut-être un
jour je n'aurai plus de mandats électifs
peut-être je mettais au golf et j'aurais
qui avait un certain niveau autant la
participation pour le moment je ne joue
pas assez pour pouvoir rivaliser mais en
tout cas j'ai beaucoup d'amis dans le
golfe j'ai enfin de velde avec qui bien
sûr là je vais encore faire une partie
du parcours et puis bon après je
soutiens aussi d'autres d'autres
golfeurs et avec franck qu'on a aussi
quelqu'un connaît bien c'est alexander
levy parce qu'il a eu lors du même point
que nous en provence et vous franck est
ce que vous y serez à ce cette deuxième
édition
non malheureusement non parce que j'ai
je vais encore du travail avec la télé
la radio donc je suis occupée voilà on a
même reçu alexander levy dans une autre
émission vestiaire parce qu'on suit tous
les sports et
ça nous intéresse et nous on aime tous
le golfe j'ai commencé en 93 puisque
chercher un palliatif à mon sport et
c'est vrai que le golf aaa permet de se
détendre mais aussi de trouver une
concentration et encore une fois de
passer un bon moment avec avec des potes
à 50 ans on est encore sportif un peu de
sportifs déjà je n'ai pas encore mes 50
ans vous avez vous calmer mais pas pour
vous mais pour les joueurs et pour les
vieux ah ouais non mais bien sûr mais on
restera jusqu'à la fin de nos jours vous
savez même mes enfants quand on était
petits on joue aux dames je n'ai pas
gagné donc bien sûr cocof on va même pas
laisser gagner ses copains on va trouver
un arrangement même sur la rive plus à
tourner voilà mais non mais le golf
associe cette cette possibilité là c'est
que jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de nos jours
jusqu'au dernier moment on peut toujours
taper dans une balle loin du niveau à
web à oui c'est moi j'ai toujours dit
que quand je vois les golfeurs
professionnels c'est pas le même sport
ils font pas le même source assez clair
nous on sent on est là on essaie moi
j'étais handicap neuf voilà mais je sais
que je fais pas de sport moi y'a des
jours des gens ont foutu là je fais du
foot comme vous n'en voulez pas fait du
foot comme moi pas pareil cesser ces
professionnels ils sont dans la minutie
on le voit gens parlent beaucoup et
thomas levet et car un gramme près sont
capables de dire s'il club il est trop
lourd ou trop légers fins et la minutie
c'est l'horlogerie suisse et même s'ils
ont 50 ans ils sont toujours meilleurs
que dams opérateurs
bien sûr que non c'est c'est comme le
vélo ça reste dans les gènes
merci à tous les deux et je rappelle le
pari les djeuns open chips et fin
septembre à saint quentin en yvelines
fin du set 8 invités pour ce soir
prochaine édition de demain aux horaires
habituels les replays sur le site
internet de tv soixante dix huit belles
soirées
[Musique]
en tout cas